[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin schönen guten abend am
längsten tag des jahres christin später
wieder mit der sportlichen einordnung an
diesem dienstag mit der rückkehr eines
weltmeisters guten abend und das sind
die themen im überblick
schwere waffen für kiew in der ukraine
sind die ersten panzerhaubitzen aus
deutschland eingetroffen die
bundesregierung veröffentlicht jetzt
alle waffenlieferungen
prozess um polizisten morde fünf monate
nach den tödlichen schüssen von kusel
muss sich der mutmaßliche täter vor
gericht verantworten
antisemitismus vorwürfe auf der
documenta tage lang steht die kunstmesse
in der kritik jetzt wird die umstrittene
installation komplett abgebaut
[Musik]
knapp vier monate ukraine krieg und fast
genauso lange drängt und bittet kiew
deutschland um schwere waffen heute
bedankte sich der ukrainische
verteidigungsminister für die lieferung
der panzerhaubitze 2000 eines der
modernsten artillerie systeme überhaupt
ukrainische soldaten wurden bei der
bundeswehr an dem system ausgebildet
sieben haubitzen hatte deutschland
zugesagt sie können dutzende kilometer
weit schießen
gleichzeitig ändert die bundesregierung
ihre eher defensive kommunikation und
veröffentlichte eine liste schon
gelieferte waffen in die ukraine wir
fragen nach in berlin bei chuck und
annabella die und in den depot in der
ost ukraine bei katrin eigendorf
zunächst zu dir schack und anna also
schwere waffen aus deutschland in der
ukraine und eine änderung in der
kommunikation wie ist das zu bewerten ja
das ist schon eine interessante
kehrtwende die die bundesregierung der
bei der kommunikation hinlegt denn es
war ja lange so dass die waffen liste
streng geheim war jetzt ist sie im
internet öffentlich zugänglich umfasst
ungefähr vier seiten und es steht
wirklich alles drauf was geliefert wurde
und noch geliefert werden soll vom
verbands brands päckchen bis zur hand
panzerhaubitze und die bundesregierung
begründet das damit dass man sich damit
an die praxis der engsten verbündeten
zum beispiel der usa anpasst die schon
länger ihre waffenlieferungen
veröffentlichen gleichwohl hat man auch
den eindruck dass es auch eine folge
sein könnte der anhaltenden kritik und
der anhaltenden rufe nach mehr
transparenz bei waffenlieferungen und
dass man so aus der defensive heraus
kommen will dazu passt auch ganz gut das
haben gerade heute die panzerhaubitzen
aus deutschland und laut unseren
informationen auch fünf niederländische
panzerhaubitzen in der ukraine
angekommen sind und das ziemlich genau
nach dem versprochenen zeitplan
allerdings wird das die debatte über die
waffenlieferungen jetzt erstmal nicht
beruhigen die union hat schon
angekündigt es müsse noch mehr kommen
noch schneller kommen die qualität der
gelieferten waffen müsse weiter steigen
und man wolle dazu noch in den bundestag
einen entsprechenden antrag einbringen
und in der ukraine denkt man
wahrscheinlich endlich kathrin welche
hoffnung verbindet sich mit den
gelieferten panzerhaubitzen aus
deutschland
erstmal wird das hier natürlich mit
großer freude und erleichterung
aufgenommen nicht nur von den militärs
sondern auch von der bevölkerung des
landes das problem ist ja dass die
russen extreme überlegenheit in der
artillerie haben und ist ist ein krieg
der mit artillerie ausgefochten wird und
das kommt jetzt gerade in einer
situation wo sich die situation hier im
don was dramatisch zuspitzt für die
ukraine sie werden wirklich von den
russen immer weiter ein gezielt das
heißt diese lieferung des ja eigentlich
modernsten waffen systems das die
ukraine jetzt hier zur verfügung haben
gibt ihnen die möglichkeit in diesem
krieg vielleicht doch wenn vielleicht
keine schnelle kehrtwende zu erzielen
aber doch zumindest die möglichkeit
diesen russischen vorschub
zurückzudrängen und damit etwas mehr
oberhand wieder in diesem krieg zu
bekommen wir werden jetzt natürlich in
den nächsten tagen sehen müssen wo
werden diese
panzerhaubitzen eingesetzt denn das ist
ja eine große frage
es gibt gebiete die sind hier so
dermaßen von russen attackiert dass es
vielleicht auch gefährlich wäre die
deutsch zu riskieren also das beobachten
wir hier mit spannung wird dieses
moderne gerät jetzt eingesetzt dann an
euch beide vielen dank für die
einschätzung nach berlin und nach
nicaragua und kathrin wir bleiben in der
ukraine der gouverneur von lukas
befürchtet moskau wolle bis sonntag die
region im osten einnehmen ins ja wie
ronny erzwangen pro russischer soldaten
jetzt ins industriegebiet vor dort
verteidigen ukrainische kämpfer nach
angaben aus kiew nur noch das chemiewerk
in dem noch zivilisten ausharren
verstärkte kämpfe werden auch im süden
erwartet während moskau in hessen
russische fernsehen ausstrahlte ruft die
ukraine zivilisten dort zuflucht auf
ein neuer konflikt zwischen der eu und
russland zeichnet sich im baltikum ab
seit samstag blockiert litauern teile
des bahn transits in die exklave
kaliningrad
die region ist nur auf dem landweg über
diese transitstrecke mit dem russischen
kernland verbunden litauen setzt damit
eu sanktionen um die einfuhr etwa von
baumaterialien kohle und metallen
natalie steger erklärt uns die
hintergründe die menschen in kaliningrad
decken sich einen baumarkt den litauern
lässt güter wie metalle stahl und
baumaterial nicht mehr über sein
staatsgebiet rein in die russische
ostsee-exklave die lager werden sich
neben
vielleicht gehen die preise hoch oder
wir werden gar keine produkte mehr
bekommen an die wir gewöhnt sind
bauarbeiten werden stoppen der
straßenbau es wird schlimmer werden
die betroffenen waren wurden bislang aus
russland via litauen in die exklave
gebracht 40 bis 50 prozent der waren
würden bald fehlen sagt der gouverneur
von kaliningrad und moskau droht
entsprechende maßnahmen werden auf
interministerieller ebene ausgearbeitet
und in naher zukunft ergriffen sie
werden ernsthafte negative folgen für
die litauische bevölkerung
die litauische regierung betont man
setze lediglich die eu sanktionen um
wegen des russischen angriff tricks in
der ukraine litauen hat kein interesse
daran irgendetwas zu eskalieren aber es
gibt die sanktionen und sie müssen
ausgeführt werden der konflikt ist für
berlin besonders pikant deutschland für
den litauern die nato-mission an hat
sein engagement zuletzt verstärkt zur
abschreckung in diesen zeiten ist es mir
wichtig dass eines ganz klar wird
deutschland steht eng an der seite
litauens und aller unserer östlichen
allierten moskau kündigte an verstärkt
waren nach kaliningrad nun über den
seeweg zu liefern wegen des transit
stritt ein weiterer konflikt der eu mit
russland ist in vollem gang
ja den ganzen land war gerade gesehen
dort beim tag der industrie in berlin
und natürlich wird auch der bestimmt von
den auswirkungen des krieges der verband
der industrie rechnet nur noch mit einem
wachstum von 1,5 prozent in diesem jahr
erst bremste corona produktion und
handel dann folgten weltweite
lieferengpässe das alles ist noch lange
nicht überwunden jetzt also auch noch
steigende energiepreise und die gefahr
eines russischen gaslieferstopps die
politik will gegensteuern und diskutiert
deshalb auch wieder über die kernkraft
karl hinterleitner
es geht um energie es geht um
versorgungssicherheit und um alte
entscheidungen die jetzt in frage stehen
oppositionsführer merz heute beim tag
der industrie mit der klaren forderung
man müsste die atomkraft weiter nutzen
wir sollten auch durchaus in erwägung
ziehen die drei noch verbliebenen
kernkraftwerke in deutschland länger
laufen zu lassen
sprengstoff in die ampel regierung
bringt der liberale koalitionspartner
der die opposition in diesem punkt
unterstützt und ein grünes tabu in frage
stellt ich wünsche mir anderes ich habe
auch wirtschaftliche bedenken auf der
langen strecke aber gegenwärtig haben
wir noch drei laufende funktionierende
kernkraftwerke
es geht nicht um einen winter den wir
jetzt überbrücken müssen sondern um drei
bis fünf jahre der sicherung unserer
energieversorgung der kanzler erteilte
dem vorstoß eine absage weiter aufklären
die zu setzen sei schlicht nicht machbar
in bezug auf atomkraft
gibt es ja doch sehr
einheitliche expertenmeinung und dem
experten meinung ist dass die brennstäbe
noch reichen bis zum jahresende insofern
gibt es wenn man genau hinschaut
eigentlich bisher niemanden denn
vorgeschlagen hat wie es geht robert
habeck sagt zur kernkraft nichts macht
aber deutlich manche entscheidungen
wolle man nicht treffen es geht nicht
anders wir müssen getrieben durch die
not des tages jetzt wieder mehr fossile
energien verbrennen und in den markt
bringen als wir eigentlich wollten
gleichwohl notwendig weil es darum geht
ich habe es eben ja schon skizziert eine
schwere ökonomische krise abzuwenden von
der gesellschaft von deutschland die
sicherheit der energieversorgung sie
verlangt schon jetzt kompromisse offen
bleibt wie weit die regierung bereit ist
zu gehen
wegen drohender gasknappheit fordern
also immer mehr politiker die laufzeiten
von atomkraftwerken zu verlängern aber
wie hilfreich wäre das eigentlich
aktuell laufen noch drei akw in
niedersachsen baden württemberg und
bayern sie liefern sechs prozent des
stroms 15 prozent werden mit erdgas
erzeugt die frage jetzt wäre er
überhaupt möglich und sinnvoll der
herausgezögerte atomausstieg bluten -
die drohende gas lücke im winter viel
diskutiert heute auf europas größter
fachmesse für energie in essen die akw
betreiber halten wenig von verlängerten
laufzeiten ihrer kraftwerke sagen es
aber nicht in die kamera
die können sie nicht einfach ab und
wieder anschalten sondern das sind lange
vorläufe für die abschalten arien und
nach meinem stand ist es seitens der
betreiber abschlägig beschieden worden
so sind die brennstäbe in den akw bis
jahresende praktisch aufgebraucht neue
beschaffen dauert mindestens ein jahr
die atomlobby sieht dennoch chancen
ja wir könnten durch bestimmte maßnahmen
in der nutzung der vorhandenen
brennelemente ein paar monate das noch
strecken dann könnte es unter umständen
eine lücke geben bis neue brennelemente
zur verfügung stehen aber für den winter
23 24 sollte es zu schaffen sein ob das
am ende hilft gas zu sparen ist jedoch
umstritten das problem pkw fahren ihre
leistungen nur langsam rauf und runter
sind deshalb geeignet für den grund
strombedarf der immer gebraucht wird
gaskraftwerke sind genau das gegenteil
sie kommen bei einem unvorhergesehenen
spitzen bedarf an strom zum einsatz
deshalb können gaskraftwerke nicht
einfach eins zu eins durch
atomkraftwerke ersetzt werden sagen
experten
insbesondere der spitzenlast eingesetzt
werden sie können schnell hoch- und
runterfahren und kommen auch nur dann
zum einsatz wenn weise eben darum mit
teuer sind atomkraftwerke sind eher auf
grundlast ausgerichtet und demnach gibt
es ja keinen direkten ersatz besser
gefüllte gasspeicher sind auf diese art
wohl nicht so leicht zu bekommen dafür
sind gaskraftwerke und akw zu
verschieden
in kaiserslautern heute erster tag im
prozess um eine tat die ende januar
tiefe trauer und entsetzen ausgelöst hat
in politik in gesellschaft und vor allem
unter den kollegen eine junge
polizeianwärterin und ein polizist
sterben als bei einer nächtlichen
fahrzeugkontrolle in der pfalz schüsse
fahren das motiv des schützen da ist
sich die anklage sicher seine wilderei
zu vertuschen über den prozessauftakt
christel haas
ein kreuz und blumen die kleine
gedenkstätte ist nur wenige schritte vom
tatort entfernt zwei von uns steht auf
der tafel zwei polizisten die erschossen
worden weil sie ihren dienst taten in
handschellen wurde heute der mutmaßliche
täter andreas es in den gerichtssaal
geführt reglos und konzentriert hörte er
der anklage zu die staatsanwaltschaft
wirft dem 39 jährigen hauptangeklagten
ein zweifach mord vor aus habgier weil
er seine beute sein jagdbeute sichern
wollte es war der 31 januar gegen 4 uhr
auf dieser kreisstraße bei kusel hatten
die beiden polizisten einen kastenwagen
kontrollieren wollen auf dessen
ladefläche getötetes wild lag eigentlich
routine doch was wollte waren schüsse
tödlich und aus nächster nähe
andreas es bestritt heute der alleinige
schütze gewesen zu sein er habe aus
notwehr auf den jungen beamten
geschossen die schüsse auf die
polizistin habe sein komplize florian v
abgegeben der ebenfalls vor gericht
geladen war dessen anwalt hält das für
eine falschaussage ich würde einfach
mutmaßen dass er
aus rache für die aussage meines
mandanten aus rache für die kooperation
meines mandanten im möglichst schaden
will als beobachter saßen auch mehrere
kollegen der polizisten im gerichtssaal
erschreckt einen doch selbst wie
gefährlich der beruf dann doch ist grad
in so doch alltäglichen routine
situation tag eins im prozess um die
morde von kusel das gericht hat 14
verhandlungstage angesetzt
wer in großbritannien auf den zug
angewiesen ist hat er heute massive
probleme zehntausende bahn beschäftigte
sind in den größten streik seit 30
jahren getreten vier von fünf passagier
zügen fuhren nicht weitere streiks
sollen donnerstag und samstag folgen die
gewerkschaften fordern bessere
arbeitsbedingungen und höhere löhne das
arbeitgeberangebot von drei prozent mehr
reiche nicht angesichts der inflation in
großbritannien die bei neun prozent
liegt
die documenta gehört zu den wichtigsten
kunstausstellungen der welt ihre
organisatoren machen jetzt nach massiven
antisemitismus-vorwürfen einen
rückzieher und lassen die umstrittene
banner installation eines indonesischen
künstlerkollektivs entfernen seit tagen
empören sich kritiker über eine
judenfeindliche bildsprache in dem werk
über die debatte reaktionen und
konsequenzen peter theißen eine
klischeehaft abwertende anspielung auf
juden ein schweins gesicht mit der
aufschrift mossad dem israelischen
geheimdienst nach meinung vieler
dokumente besucher ist das eindeutig
antisemitische kunst es ist ganz klar
erkennbar antisemitisch oder anti
israelisch und rassistisch so wenn man
das klar feststellt dann kann es nicht
sagen dass die stadt kassel diesen
leuten den öffentlichen raum zur
verfügung stellt kasse steht eigentlich
für freiheit die menschen sind hier
offen so was sollte eigentlich einfach
nicht hingehören die chefin der
dokumente heftig unter druck
entschuldigt sich heute auch für das
indonesische kuratorenteam gemeinsam mit
roo an grupa dem artistik team und den
künstlerinnen und künstlern haben wir
versichert dass auf der documenta
fifteen keine antisemitischen inhalte zu
sehen sein werden andernfalls würden wir
umgehend einschreiten dieses versprechen
haben wir leider nicht gehalten und das
hätte nicht passieren dürfen schon im
vorfeld der documenta gab es heftige
diskussionen über und hinweise auf
antisemitismus wenn man hätte hinhören
wollen da gab es im vorfeld genügend
ermahnungen es gab im vorfeld die sorge
vor antisemitismus und wenn es dann
nicht gelingt im vorfeld sich die
dargestellten objekte auch genau
anzuschauen dann muss man sagen da hat
man auch nicht hinschauen wollen nach
den heftigen protesten wurde das
umstrittene banner verhüllt noch heute
soll es ganz aus dem stadtbild
verschwinden die diskussion um
antisemitismus auf der dokumente aber
erst die gluthitze und dann krachende
unwetter in oberbayern folgte ein wetter
extrem auf das andere in moosburg an der
isar stürzten bäume nach einem
hagelsturm auf die straße und erschlugen
einen radfahrer mehrere menschen wurden
verletzt in der 20.000 einwohner stadt
und im gesamten umland fiel der strom
aus der zugverkehr zwischen freising und
landshut musste eingestellt werden
jetzt zum sport und der dritten silber
medaille bei der schwimm wm in ungarn
das wird das futter genau das kann sich
doch sehen lassen ich find's klasse
passt ja fast hätte es für florian
wellbrock über acht meter freistil zu wm
gold in budapest gereicht doch im
schlussspurt hatte wieder einmal der
amerikaner bobby fink die nase von also
silber für wellbrock in neuer deutscher
rekordzeit florian wellbrock
olympia-vierter diesmal soll es klappen
mit einer medaille über 800 meter mit
romantschuk aus der ukraine vorlauf
schnellster und auf einladung welt box
dessen trainingspartner in magdeburg auf
bahn 6 noch titelverteidiger ball
trainieren und auf 7 überraschungs
olympiasieger bobby fink showdown auf
der letzten bahn romantschuk führt vor
wellbrock und ball trainieren wie finke
aber ganz links noch dran und der
amerikaner hat einen gigantischen
schlussspurt wellbrock atmet nach rechts
zieht also nur romantschuk den pelzer in
schach gewinnt also silber weltmeister
aber wird vor dem deutschen
olympiasieger bobby fink
und soeben ist lukas matzerath im finale
über 50 meter brust auf platz sechs
geschwungen die rückkehr von mario götze
in die fußball bundesliga ist nun
perfekt der 30 jährige mittelfeldspieler
wechselt von endhoven zum europa league
sieger eintracht frankfurt er
unterschrieb einen dreijahresvertrag und
freue sich zitat wahnsinnig berlin ist
von donnerstag bis sonntag wieder
schauplatz eines großen nationalen sport
events die finale zdf und ard bereiten
sich auf mehr als 25 stunden
live-übertragungen vor in 14 sportarten
werden insgesamt 190 deutsche
meistertitel vergeben unter anderem in
der leichtathletik im kanu triathlon und
auch im bogenschießen
der deutsche eishockey profi niko sturm
kassierte im nhl playoff finale mit der
colorado avalanche die erste niederlage
trotz führung verlor colado auswärts das
dritte spiel bei titelverteidiger tampa
bay lightning klar mit 2 6 zum gewinn
des stanley cups sind vier siege
notwendig colorado führt in der serie
mit 2 zu 1 und morgen nacht geht es
bereits schon weiter dann fielen dank
christin wir haben zum schluss noch eine
ungewöhnliche aktion zugunsten der
ukraine dmitri muratow auf russische
journalistin und kreml kritiker hat
nämlich seine friedens nobelpreis
medaille versteigert den zuschlag
erhielt ein anonymer bieter für 103
millionen dollar die sollen jetzt
geflüchteten ukrainischen kindern zugute
kommen eine aktion die zu menschlichkeit
und mut aufruft in zeiten des krieges
und der krisen das kann ich ihnen auch
schon sagen morgen im norden sonnig im
süden neue gewitter mehr dazu gleich mit
christa oben wir empfehlen das heute
journal mit christian sievers um 21 uhr
45 genießen sie diesen hellen abend
ungefähr zwei stunden bleibt nämlich
noch hell danke fürs zuschauen und
bismarck
[Musik]
guten abend heute ist ja sommeranfang
der längste tag des jahres in münchen
zum beispiel vergehen zwischen sonnenauf
und sonnenuntergang heute 16 stunden und
vier minuten in hamburg dass es
nördlicher da sind es sogar 17 stunden
und 3 minuten und fiel von dieser zeit
stehen heute die sonne wie das
satellitenbild zeigt allerdings kamen
von südwest noch immer mal wolken rein
und das auch genau dort wo jetzt heute
abend und in der nacht teils kräftige
schauer und gewitter unterwegs sein
können aber erstmal nur vereinzelt
richtung norden ist es oft klar da kühlt
es in der nacht auch teils ab auf 7 bis
12 grad in der gewitter luft ist es
milder bei 13 bis 18 grad morgen haben
wir an den küsten temperaturen um die 20
grad sonst ist es verbreitet sommerlich
bei werten zwischen 25 und 30 grad und
im norden ist es dazu auch richtig
sonnig nur in schleswig-holstein bleibt
es unter dem hochnebel etwas bedeckter
richtung süden aber im saarland
rheinland pfalz bayern und baden
württemberg sind schauer und gewitter
unterwegs zum einen noch morgens aus der
nacht zum anderen dann nachmittags
wieder kräftiger vereinzelt können da
unwetter mit starkregen hagel und
sturmböen dabei sein ab donnerstag geht
es dann sommerlich warm bis heiß weiter
am freitag der entwickelt sich
allerdings einige wetterlage vor allem
im westen des landes mit unwettergefahr
schönen abend noch